la russie de son côté souhaite la tenue
d'une réunion d'urgence au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies moscou qui
n'a pas d'ailleurs annoncé ne pas
vouloir évacuer son ambassade à kaboul
on en parle avec notre correspondante à
moscou vera goffman
bonjour verrait alors pouvez vous nous
en dire plus sur la position de la
russie
bonjour amis raël la russie et ses
partenaires oeuvre pour la tenue d'une
réunion d'urgence du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu sur la situation en afghanistan
communiqué l'envoyé spécial russe pour l
afghanistan à venir kaboul off elle a
assuré que cette réunion devait se tenir
très bientôt selon kaboul of la russie à
la différence des états unis ne prépare
pas l'évocation de son ambassade en
afghanistan la mission diplomatique
russe travaille de façon sereine et suit
de près l'évolution de la situation dans
le pays les talibans avaient auparavant
garantit la sécurité aurait sorti sans
russe en sic aux autres missions
diplomatiques pour la porte parole du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
marie et zakharova en afghanistan
s'affrontent en ce moment les deux
forces créé par les états unis je vous
propose d'écouter
cela peut surprendre mais c'est en fait
en afghanistan se déroule en
affrontement entre deux forces qui sont
toutes deux le fruit du processus
réflexif des états unis le monde suit
avec horreur le résultat d'une énième
expérience historique de washington
les talibans ont lancé leur offensive en
mai en la faveur du début du retrait
final des troupes américaines qui doit
être achevé d'ici le 31 août face à
cette offensive jo baden a décidé le 14
août de porter à quint à 5000 soldats le
déploiement militaire de kaboul pour
assurer la sécurité des l'évacuation du
civil tout en défendant sa décision de
mettre fin à 20 ans de guerre en
afghanistan
merci à vera pour toutes ces précisions